hey 42 here niagara falls is one of the
most instantly recognizable and
spectacular sights on the planet
a breathtaking natural wonder that's
been captivating people for hundreds of
years
every second over 3000 tons of water
thunders over the falls generating
enough energy to power millions of homes
it's actually a group of free waterfalls
which straddle the border between the
usa and canada
they are situated on the niagara river
which flows from lake erie into lake
ontario
the largest of these waterfalls is the
horseshoe falls at a staggering 823
metres wide and 51 meters high closely
followed by the american falls and
finally the much smaller bridal veil
falls
it was formed over 12 000 years ago
during the end of the last ice age when
the entire niagara region was still
covered in huge glaciers
as the ice age came to an end and the
ice began to melt the soil beneath
eroded forming vast basins
over time these filled with water which
inevitably overflowed causing torrents
of water to snake its way across the
land slowly but surely forming the
niagara river
and ultimately the falls themselves
[Music]
now if i ask you to stand on the
precipice of one of these waterfalls and
throw your fragile body into the vast
watery abyss
just hoping you win mother nature's
lottery and avoid snapping your neck on
impact
miss all the jagged rocks and somehow
manage not to get dragged under and
drowned
what would you say
oh what's that
no i really thought you were going to go
for yes there
but in 1829 that's sort of what happened
when a man named sam patch jumped into
the niagara river below
sam patch who took the moniker of the
yankee leaper was the first american
daredevil he'd spent his life leaping
off increasingly taller waterfalls in
front of pensive crowds
and what could be a great surprise than
the granddaddy of waterfalls in north
america niagara falls
although it wasn't quite as impressive
as it sounds patch didn't jump from the
top of one of the falls but from a 25
meter tall ladder erected at the base of
goat island in the middle of the river
this was still an impressive feat mind
you and he repeated it again a few
months later but from a higher elevation
of 36 meters to the marvel of 10 000
onlookers
unfortunately patch had little time to
enjoy his newfound fame
barely a month later he died whilst
attempting a similar jump into the
genesee river in new york
but patch wasn't the first person to
realize that chucking stuff off
waterfalls can draw a large crowd two
years before he arrived at the falls an
eccentric hotel proprietor by the name
of william forsythe managed to attract
his own crowd of ten thousand curious
folk
without even having to get his feet wet
you see in order to gain the upper hand
in the competitive niagara hotel trade
forsythe wanted to advertise his
pavilion hotel in a way that would
guarantee widespread notoriety
his idea was pretty simple and also a
bit bonkers
he purchased an old boat and decorated
it to look like a pirate ship he even
filled it with a crew of mannequins all
dressed up in the kind of threads that
blackbeard himself would be proud of
once the pirate ship was ready it was
floated downstream and over the falls
for the entertainment of the crowd
a bit mental sure but it sounds pretty
entertaining right
i'd pay to see that
but forsythe wasn't finished yet
to add another layer of excitement to
this eccentric pie
he filled his pirate ship with a
menagerie of live animals
a buffalo a dog two raccoons two foxes
two bears
fifteen geese
and an eagle to be exact
yeah i'm not sure how those poor animals
felt about this arrangement
the crowd watched on curiously as the
animal-filled pirate ship floated itself
downstream towards its watery fate
however before it arrived at the drop
the bears managed to escape and swim to
safety
the others wouldn't be so lucky and all
but one seemingly invincible goose
perished at the foot of the falls
this technically made it the first
documented living creature to have
survived a trip over niagara falls
unfortunately you won't find its goosey
face in any of the record books
but you will find the face of annie
edson taylor a 63 year old school
teacher who by 1901 had apparently
become bored of teaching general
arithmetic to unruly school kids
and decided she wanted to become the
first person to go over niagara falls
and survive
to be fair to annie if i spent 10
minutes trying to teach maths to a room
of 10 year olds i'd throw myself off a
waterfall
to maximize her chances of survival
annie fought it prudent to bundle
herself into a wooden barrel to be fair
it was a pimped out barrel custom made
for the job at hand constructed of oak
reinforced with iron hoops and padded
with a mattress
before taylor herself attempted the
stunt the barrel was rigorously tested
in a series of high-tech safety
experiments and it emerged with a
five-star end cap safety rating
actually that's not true at all they
just sent it over the falls with a cat
inside to see if it would survive
which thankfully it did
although it did have a bleeding head
which would set alarm bells ringing for
me but not for annie
so now that it was kitty approved it was
annie's turn to attempt to defeat she
climbed inside with her lucky
heart-shaped pillow in hand
the barrel was plugged up and thrown
into a rowboat which took her to the
center of the river before being set
adrift towards the mighty horseshoe
falls and finally plunging her way into
the history
despite a small head wound taylor was
pulled from the barrel mostly unscathed
although she would later tell the press
i would sooner walk up to the mouth of a
cannon knowing it was going to blow me
to pieces
than make another trip over the falls
she'd hoped fame and fortune would be
awaiting her
making money was the reason she decided
to do this crazy stunt in the first
place but it never materialized and
despite going down in history as the
first person to intentionally go over
niagara falls and survive
she would live out her days in poverty
it would be another decade before
someone else attempted to repeat
taylor's stunt
this time it was a circus performer by
the name of bobby leach
bobby leach was a bit of a regular at
niagara he'd already performed a 63
meter high dive into the river and tried
and failed to traverse the rapids
and now he turned his attention to the
falls themselves bragging to local
residents that anything a 63 year old
school teacher could do he could do
better
in spite of his confidence he didn't
better taylor's plunge although leech
survived he came away with two broken
kneecaps a few broken ribs and a
fractured jaw
but only 15 years later this brave titan
of the falls
died in the most embarrassing way
he slipped on an orange peel
[Music]
other daredevils have taken to the skies
above niagara to prove their metal
many tight rope walkers have descended
upon or should that be ascended upon
anyway upon niagara in the hope of
walking the full width of the falls
without falling in the most famous of
them being the phenombialist charles
blondon who in 1859 executed a series of
daring tightrope walks across the
niagara gorge in front of 25 000
onlookers
by the way you may assume like i did
that a phenomenalist is someone who
inappropriately fondles ambulances
no just me
but it's actually the proper name for a
tightrope walker derived from the latin
word funnis meaning rope and ambulair
meaning to walk but sure enough ambulair
is also where we derive the word
ambulance from
hospital ambulance being the 19th
century french name for a mobile
hospital
but anyway back at niagara falls
somebody who was desperately hoping to
avoid the need for an ambulance was
charles blondon not content with merely
fanambuling his way across the river on
a rope suspended 50 meters in the air
which if you ask me is already pretty
impressive
blunden upped the difficulty level of
each walk with a series of increasingly
ambitious theatrical stunts
these included wearing a blindfold
pushing a wheelbarrow wearing stilts and
at one point stopping in the middle to
cook and eat an omelet
he even completed the walk whilst
carrying his manager on his back now if
that doesn't demonstrate faith in your
employees abilities then i don't know
what does
blondin was already a mega star of his
day but his famous tightrope walks
across the niagara gorge only helped to
boost his fame even further
and if you ever find yourself in london
be sure to look out for blunden avenue
and niagara avenue both named in honor
of blondin and his heroics
of course not all stunts at niagara have
ended in celebration
in 1883 the englishman matthew webb
attempted to swim through the dangerous
and unpredictable niagara whirlpool a
feat that nobody had dared attempt
before
and for good reason the whirlpool is one
of the largest of its type in the world
at over a thousand feet wide and 120
feet deep
but webb was no ordinary swimmer in 1875
he'd become the first person in recorded
history to swim the english channel
without use of artificial aids a swim
that had taken him an exhausting 22
hours
unfortunately despite his pedigree he
proved no match for the mighty niagara
whirlpool
webb was sucked into the vortex and
pulled beneath the surface
his mangled body was found four days
later washed up downstream
since annie edson taylor first took the
plunge at the beginning of the 20th
century a total of 13 people have
attempted to beat the falls with nine of
them living to tell the tale
in 1951 the niagara authorities decided
it was probably a good idea to stop
people profiting from going over the
falls and so it was made illegal
this meant the glory days of huge crowds
gathering to watch someone quite
literally risking life and limb
were over
however this didn't stop the occasional
unlicensed attempt take jessie sharp for
instance who in 1990 went over the falls
in a kayak
he was so confident he'd survive that
he'd made dinner reservations at a
restaurant down river unfortunately but
unsurprisingly it was a reservation that
he was unable to keep
due to him being dead
today niagara falls remains a hugely
popular tourist hotspot
each year millions of people arrive from
all corners of the globe to gaze upon
this gargantuan curtain of water and
witness its breathtaking power
but one day this geological wonder will
cease to exist
you see the free waterfalls are eroding
at a rate of around 30 centimeters a
year
and it's estimated that they are now
seven miles upstream from their original
position efforts have been made to slow
this process with underwater tunnels
being constructed to divert the most
damaging currents away from the falls
and in 1969 a temporary dam was built up
river
to drain the falls completely so that
weak points could be located and
strengthened
in spite of these efforts very little
can stand in the way of mother nature
and niagara falls will one day merge
into lake erie before disappearing
completely but before you start
panicking about not being able to
complete that bucket list of yours i
should point out that this won't happen
for at least another 20 000 years
which should give you plenty of time to
save up a bit of spending money and
maybe even treat yourself to a
state-of-the-art reinforced wooden
barrel whilst you're there
just don't do anything stupid with it
thanks for watching
check out my new podcast random
interesting facts available on youtube
spotify apple podcast and anywhere else
you get your podcasts link in the
description below thanks